hey what is up everybody it's anna mack
here for
anime operor and today i will be
explaining
and breaking down aaron's decision to
attack lebario
and basically declare war on the whole
world
just as the world was preparing to
declare war on him aaron made this
decision against the wishes of his
closest friends
and this one single choice completely
changed the world of attack on titan but
more than that
it transformed aaron jaeger into a
completely different person and one of
the darkest
and most unique anime protagonists of
all time
this was a major turning point in the
attack on titan story
and in the life of aaron yeager and that
is what i will be talking about
in this video if you enjoy our attack on
titan content and you want us to keep it
going please do me a favor and leave a
like
it really does help and of course if
you're new to the channel or you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications before we get into it
a quick thank you to tree of life
audreya for sponsoring this video tree
of life audria
is a brand new survival online game that
throws a bunch of players onto a strange
island
and pits them against the environment
and against each other
imagine this you wake up shipwrecked on
a strange island
and now your very survival depends on
your choices
you have to find resources and tools
build your new home
and either cooperate or compete with
other players
will you be a friend or an enemy to your
fellow survivors
will you protect your village from enemy
attackers or will you fall victim to a
craftier player
enjoy the awesome graphics the vibrant
gameplay and the thriving player based
economy build your own village anywhere
on the map
solve ancient mysteries and fight for
survival
tree of life audria is still a brand new
game
in fact it's so new that it still hasn't
been released
but if you want to be one of the first
to play and dominate this game
click the link in the description and
add this game to your steam
wishlist that way you will be notified
when the game comes out and you can get
a head start
on the competition just click the top
link in the description and
add tree of life audrey to your wish
list right now
now in a previous attack on titan video
that i made specifically about the epic
reunion of reiner and aaron
i discussed in detail aaron's state of
mind
and why he decided to attack liberio in
that exact moment
i talked about the parallels between
reiner's attack on aaron's hometown and
aaron's game-changing counter-attack on
reiner's hometown
the main focus of this video is the
unbelievable impact of aaron's attack on
the barrio on the entire world of attack
on titan
and on aaron as a character even aaron's
closest friends and comrades including
mikasa armin hanji and
others were opposed to this plan aaron
basically made the decision to
infiltrate liberio and carry out the
attack
on his own without prior approval from
his superiors
in the survey core he essentially forced
the survey core's hand by sending them
notes
through falco we didn't get to see the
contents of those notes but presumably
aaron told the survey corps that he was
planning to attack and they felt
compelled to come and support
him because paradise simply could not
afford to lose the founding and attack
titans in case aaron's plan
failed in terms of the direct
geopolitical consequences
aaron's attack on the burial and the
killing of marland military leaders
along with many leaders of the other
countries basically started a world war
all of the countries whose
representatives were present in liberia
during the attack would now likely ally
with marley to destroy paradise
once and for all many of eren's comrades
were upset with aaron because of this
they felt that the attack ensured that
the world would hate the aliens on the
island even more
and now the whole world will actively
work together to destroy parodies
but aaron was convinced that this war
was inevitable
the marlenes and their allies were going
to attack paradise anyway
so might as well hit them first and try
to take the warhammer titan before this
titan can also be used to attack the
island
and the truth is aaron has a point
the whole purpose of the festival in
liberio was to declare war on parodies
so whether or not aaron attacked it
would have happened anyway
and in their previous attempts to find a
peaceful solution
the survey corps members had
consistently run into dead ends because
everyone in marley and in most countries
of the world hates the ldns on parodies
and wants to destroy them
i mean even the aldians in marleigh hate
their fellow aliens on parodies and want
to eradicate them
and in general the so-called island
devils are constantly blamed for all of
the world's problems
so aaron is right the war was inevitable
and a peaceful solution was pretty much
impossible and not for a lack of trying
his attack on the barrio may have made
the world hate the aldians on the island
even
more but at least it gave aaron the
chance to gain an additional advantage
in the inevitable war to come by
attempting to capture the warhammer
titan so yes
we can definitely say that while aaron's
attack on the barrio contributed to
turning the world against
the aliens on parodies even more it only
hastened
the inevitable however the true impact
of aaron's decision to attack liberio
is evident when we take a look at aaron
as a character
aaron started out as a somewhat typical
protagonist for a shonen series
he has a tragic backstory and this
backstory inspires him to give it his
all and fight to protect his loved ones
from these gigantic
inhuman monsters he gets a cool
superpower he can turn into a titan
and he uses it to fight the other titans
at that point it's clear that aaron is
the good guy
and the giant monsters are the bad guys
since the titans are mindless monsters
whose sole purpose is to devour humans
killing them is just self-defense it's
the right thing to do
and no one could possibly judge a shonen
protagonist for killing these monsters
except as we learn later the titans
are not just random mindless monsters
every single one of them was once a
human being
and most of them were turned into titans
through no fault of their own
by that point it was clear that attack
on titan is far more complex and far
darker than the average shown in story
and that is why many would argue that
attack on titan
is not a shonen at all in terms of its
mature themes and complex world building
it seems to be closer to a seinen than a
shonen but
technically the demographic for attack
on titan is classified as shonen and the
manga is published in a shonen magazine
the reason that i bring up all of this
shonen stuff is because i want to
emphasize just how different aaron is
from the vast majority of other
protagonists
and shonen protagonists in particular
and his decision to
attack liberio is the turning point at
which aaron breaks with the conventions
established for protagonists and
especially
in terms of shonen when mika sanaran
finally reunite
it happens in the middle of aaron's
attack by that point he is already
fighting the warhammer titan and he has
already killed a large number of people
including willie tiber and the marland
military leadership
but as mikasa somberly points out
aaron's attack has also killed a number
of innocent civilians
including children mikasa asks aaron how
he could do this
and how he could possibly live with
something like this on his conscience
and that is the moment that aaron truly
becomes a completely
different kind of protagonist unlike the
vast majority of other anime
protagonists
aaron is willing to kill and not just
like one or two bad guys
he is prepared to kill many many people
including innocent civilians who may get
caught
in the crossfire now of course hurting
civilians is not aaron's intention
that is not what he set out to do but he
knows that civilians will inevitably
suffer
as a result of his attack and yet he
goes through with the attack
anyway now this is the tragic reality of
war
and even in our own world where we have
so-called precision guided missiles that
are designed to hit a specific target
without causing a lot of collateral
damage
we know that collateral damage still
happens all the time
even if the intended target is a
genuinely evil person who has done
horrible things
whenever you launch a missile or
dispatch an army unit to take down a
target
there is a risk that innocent people
will get caught in the crossfire
and unfortunately very often that is
exactly what happens
but even though this is the tragic truth
about war
the vast majority of anime and manga
protagonists would never cross
that line many go out of their way not
to kill at all
and others kill only very evil people
and only if they have no
other choice i mean can you imagine deku
goku
luffy naruto or osta willingly causing
the deaths of dozens of
innocent people it just wouldn't happen
there are protagonists who used to do
bad things but then they change their
ways like meliotas from the seminally
sins
and there are protagonists who willingly
kill for what they believe is a greater
good
like for example light yagami from death
note but even someone like light
a man who has killed thousands of people
specifically targets criminals and those
who directly got in the way
of his master plan light is a good
comparison to aaron in many ways
but one could argue that aaron's
decisions are even more morally
questionable than lights
because while a death note allows the
user to target specific
people aaron attacked in a more
indiscriminate way
that ended up involving completely
innocent civilians
and even within the world of attack on
titan many of the characters who have
been close to aaron for years
actively oppose his strategy in liberio
during the liberio attack itself we see
mikasa
sasha jean and others going out of their
way to avoid civilian casualties as much
as possible
and all of these people went through the
same type of trauma as aaron did
and all of them have just as much of a
right to hate the marlians as
aaron does but still there are some
lines that they are simply not willing
to cross
and willingly hurting civilians is one
of those lines
but aaron is a brutal realist he
recognizes that in war
collateral damage is regrettable but
often inevitable
and since the marlene's decided to bring
the war to his doorstep
he will bring it right back to their
doorstep aaron is willing to do whatever
it takes to be free
and to protect the people he cares about
and he is prepared to pay
any price in order to achieve his goals
most philosophical schools throughout
history from pre-christian thinkers like
socrates and the stoics to christian and
other religious philosophers
would say that doing what aaron has done
will ultimately tarnish his
own soul many would say that accepting
death is actually preferable to doing
what aaron has done
because by choosing to go through with
the attack and kill innocent people in
the process
aaron has condemned his own soul to an
eternity of suffering
aaron has corrupted his soul he has done
inexcusable things that will never be
forgiven
and to some this is a fate worse than
death
what is the point of living if you are
forced to live as a monster
if you are forced to become everything
that you have always hated
however aaron rejects all of these
philosophies
and he embraces a philosophy that is
very similar to the writings of italian
philosopher nicola machiavelli i made an
entire video talking about aaron's
philosophy in detail
and in that video i talked at length
about how machiavellian aaron's
philosophy really is
if you want to see that video you can
check it out link in the description but
to be brief
machiavelli believes that defending his
country and his people from a cruel and
ruthless world
must be prioritized and it must be
achieved by
any means necessary failing to do what
it takes to protect your homeland and
your people will only result in more
wars and more suffering in the future if
you have to kill
or cheat or steal to achieve this goal
then this is exactly what you must do
machiavelli is not saying that you
should be immoral he is saying that
sitting back and doing nothing while
your people suffer
would be the truly immoral act sure you
might feel better about yourself if you
never get your hands dirty and you
certainly won't feel the kind of guilt
that someone who does what aaron did is
going to feel
but machiavelli would say that this is a
selfish act
not doing anything to protect your
people in your homeland because you're
worried about corrupting your own soul
is wrong and that's because by choosing
not to do what needs to be done to
destroy the enemy
you are condemning your own people to
suffer at the hands of that same enemy
machiavelli loves his people and his
country
more than his own soul and he is willing
to blacken his soul with sin
if that sin will save his people and i
think that aaron
embraces that same philosophy he is
willing to do whatever it takes
he is willing to accept collateral
damage on a massive scale
and he is willing to bear all of that
crippling guilt on his shoulders
in the name of achieving his goals at
the end of the day
many people will disagree with aaron's
actions and many philosophical and
religious schools of thought
would absolutely condemn aaron for what
he has done
but you don't have to agree with aaron's
actions to recognize that he is an
extremely
well-written character and that he has
undergone
one of the most incredible character
developments in
all of fiction aaron is a completely
different kind of protagonist
and his story and the story of attack on
titan is going to be remembered by anime
fans for decades to come
aaron's character development and his
willingness to cross a line that most
protagonists would absolutely never
cross
make him one of the most memorable
characters in fiction and for me
aaron's transformation is one of the
main reasons why attack on titan is
already without a doubt
a modern classic if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
attack on titan content on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying it's an extra
step but if you don't do that you're
still going to miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram
at animeopror as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you